près de dix mille nouveaux cas en 24
heures est la reprise épidémique se
confirme en france depuis plusieurs
jours les chiffres sont mauvais et
certains scientifiques parlent déjà
d'une cinquième vague une situation qui
inquiète l'exécutif face à cette
nouvelle flambée emmanuel m'apprend doit
prendre la parole mardi soir le chef de
l'état ne manquera pas de rappeler
l'importance des gestes barrières alors
qu'un relâchement et remarqué il devrait
également aborder le sujet de la
vaccination une allocution très attendue
qui a poussé soixante trois mille
personnes à prendre rendez vous sur doc
tollitte pour une troisième dose de
vaccin un record alors à quoi faut-il
s'attendre pour endiguer l'épidémie
éléments de réponse avec asf charge
on n'est pas sorti de l'épidémie ces
mots ce sont ceux de jean castex en
déplacement à montpellier le 5 novembre
le premier ministre a fait un point sur
la situation sanitaire du pays évoquant
une reprise épidémique même son cloche
du côté du porte parole du gouvernement
en marge de sa visite d'une pharmacie
parisienne vendredi c'était cool et le
taux d'incidence au niveau national est
désormais au dessus de 60 je rappelle
que le seuil d alerte est à 50 nous
constatons que le taux de reproduction
du virus c'est à dire le fameux air
s'établir durablement au-dessus de 1 et
que les hospitalisations repartent
légèrement à la hausse ces derniers
jours nous avons nous sommes donc face à
une haie dont nous ignorons à ce stade
la hauteur mais nous avons une
conviction c'est que nous pouvons la
franchir ensemble parce que nous
disposons des outils qui nous
permettront de la franchir ces outils
vous le savez c'est la vigilance
collective ce sont les gestes barrière
c'est aussi la vaccination parmi les
outils évoqué par gabri à la tall ceux
contenus dans le projet de loi vigilance
sanitaire définitivement validé cette
semaine par l'assemblée nationale
il y a d'abord le pass sanitaire qui
pourra être utilisée jusqu'au 31 juillet
2022 ainsi que le statut de sortie de
l'état d'urgence qui permette à
l'éxécutif d'appliquer des mesures
restrictives
le juge nécessaire sans oublier la
troisième dose de vaccin elle concerne
pour le moment les plus de 65 ans et les
plus fragiles mais le gouvernement
pourrait l'étendre à l'ensemble de la
population
et pourquoi pas même conditionné le pass
sanitaires à cette nouvelle injection il
serait légitime de s'interroger sur la
validité du pass après plus de six mois
de l'acsi nation si au cas où vous
auriez par exemple plus de 70 ans ou un
diabète grave les études attester qu'il
y aurait un risque de ne plus être
suffisamment protégés contre les formes
graves une troisième dose qu emmanuel
macron devrait prochainement évoqué le
chef de l'état doit s'adresser aux
français mardi à 20h